definitely it has to be a deeper  understanding of the importance of place  in policy we've come to understand that  health education security economic  development happens in place and place  can be a incredible lengths to  understand how to improve policies  across governments in different cities  in the world for example if we talk  about crime an urban crime we've come to  understand how important is our  neighborhoods to to understand how the  violence and crime is happening in  cities so if we can design better  strategies targeting places not very not  just general strategies for cities but  very specific strategies targeting the  most troubled neighborhoods will be much  better at an addressing urban crime that  we've been so far